[Applause]
[Music]
you know I think a lot of young artists
they you know they Revere you so they
they look to you the other thing you
inspire is Impressions people doing
impressions now when people do
impressions of you is it like sort of
nails on a chalkboard or do you kind of
enjoy it
no I I kind of enjoy it especially if
they do it well
uh so no I I it's great it's
I love it I only ask
no because because any hiddlestone is
watching will know uh Tom Hiddleston
does impressive you do write pressure so
who is in your Cannon it's a it's a
expression of admiration just to be
clear
um so I do I do uh impressions of people
that I I admire and I sort of listen to
them I get the first time I did an
impression
um anyone was aware of I was just
telling a story about midnight in Paris
the Woody Allen film I was in and how I
never read the whole script and I and I
thought it was set in the 20s and um I
turned up and I bonded to Owen Wilson
who didn't look like he was in the 20s
at all
and uh and I said to him I said so wait
hang on who are you playing because I'm
playing F Scott Fitzgerald and I know
Corey stalls playing Ernest Hemingway
and we're all playing figures of history
and he went oh no no no no no I'm from
now when I go back
there's there's a time machine
it's kind of cool and it's kind of Woody
and you just kind of it's kind of
Awesome
I've been made to do impressions of my
fellow Avengers
um uh I think everyone does an
impression of Christopher Walken because
he's just he's such an easy kind you
know I feel like what this show needs
it's more cowbell
depends on what
you'd like me to say
basically there's no
punctuation
anything that comes out of my mouth
I like that
I know whole pages of heat you surprised
me
so I there's this there's a scene in the
middle of the film which you'll be
familiar with you were there
the one person you don't need to explain
it
he remembers
in the middle of the film which is
because because Al Pacino and Robert De
Niro
who's that I'm sorry buddy they're
separated like a great Thriller they're
separated from for the entire film and
they meet twice once at the end or once
in the middle and it takes place at a
restaurant La it's a great scene it's
one of the great pieces of screen acting
you can hope to watch there it is it
says a picture of it it's like a it's a
mutual recognition of each other anyway
so there's a bit where they have like
they sit and have coffee and have tea
and talk about stuff I'm going on I
apologize
anyway so Al Pacino at one point Al
Pacino says this he goes uh
so
[Laughter]
we're sitting here like a couple of
regular fellas I mean uh
you do what you do
I do what I gotta do
if I'm there
and I gotta put you away
I don't like it
but if it's between you
and some poor bastard whose wife are
gonna turn into a widow
brother
you are going down
and then and then and so then and then
and then Michael Mann Cuts back to the
esteemed gentleman at the end of the
sofa
foreign
I'm not gonna put you down
moving face to face
yeah
but I will not hesitate
not for a second
that's my
this is so this is So Meta
I feel like I've gone into a parallel
universe
yes I apologize
I've ever seen yeah still yeah
but my favorite seed that was written
before not because of doing it but just
my favorite scene written in the film
you know that that's a great piece of
rice yeah it feels like it plays in Two
in two singles in a way like yeah yeah
and it's it's like the most beautiful
game of tennis did you each do lots of
takes would you do lots of texting you
get that many take screen there I don't
think we did more than
five to eight or nine at the moment
maybe maybe less
they talk about your dreams and you talk
about your life
it's so great it's so great there's a
bit another bit where you go
you know you said sir he says uh Pacino
says
so you never wanted a regular type life
and and uh Bob may I call you Bob yeah
Bob says um what's that barbecues and
ball games
divided by fear
one man must stand alone Will Smith Ryan
Reynolds Catherine Zeta Joe Toby Jones
Graham Norton's pants rated off
my ringtone
okay this is very good just try this one
try this one Jamie you've got is there
any cockneys in the house
can you use it in a sentence yeah yeah
you could so but try to sign that
quarter Panda there you go
panda with cheese with fries
[Applause]
there was a uh a Nigerian comedian that
was talking about my performance in the
movie and he he said uh he said uh Will
Smith he's doing a Nigerian accent in
his film and the haters will say that it
is no good but I think that is not true
I think he sounds like a Nigerian with a
concussion
thank you that is very good
we were doing Chewbacca during the clip
in time with the tube I can think just a
natural ninja that's one of my favorites
[Music]
and then he leaves
that's it
going on
[Applause]
thank you that's I'm doing a Harrison
Ford one-man show
in the West End
it's a theater reference
Daisy you got to use your lovely English
voice I do throughout I do John not so
much no I have an American accent do it
he's so good no it's incredible your
accent is so good I think I mean I tried
it in the British but it didn't work out
I'm a stormtrooper and they have a
savior
didn't work out
oh I've seen preparations
are you all right
yo give me fun seeing Sun hot dog in a
bun kiss me quick drink and spit stick a
pod line a picnic if it
um
four actors you know you all have to do
accents but Ryan we don't think of
Canadians as having accents and yet
usually do you've lost your accent you
would say yeah I sort of trained myself
out of it but you know I go back home
and it it pops up again it's uh that's
all out of the way I hear that's all
Ottawa oh yeah
let's say about uh it's a Well in Canada
it's a boat that's what I'm saying say
it the way you say what do you talk
about what are you talking about but
it's all about everything is I I it's a
bad word but I'm sorry so you handle
everything with oh [__] buddy
[Laughter]
hello how are you you like my English
accent
it's very nice very well thank you
cheerio
so I like I like British accents because
they're so sexy
[Applause]
we'll we'll talk to you later bye-bye
believers
okay
this is gonna be beautiful
[Music]
okay
you with the [__]
don't be discouraged oh I realize
it's hard to take courage in the world
full of people
you can lose sight of it all in the
darkness inside you can make you feel so
small but I see your true killers
[Music]
how beautiful
like a rainbow
[Applause]
stay there I'm enjoying this introduce
buddy Tyler right it's time to music
hahaha
[Applause]
so welcome back welcome back
um
so to you
you've never been on the show
sometimes you picture me I'm walking too
far ahead you're calling to me I can't
hear what you have said then you'll say
go slow
Tom Cruise is doing you know Jeremy
McGuire so they had the guy sees me read
in L.A he says yo I want you to go to
read for for TC in New York I said who
TC
Tom Cruise all the old Tom Cruise so I
go to read but as I'm reading I'm loud
show me the money you know what I mean
right that's all I'm saying brother show
me the money
Tom Cruise reads his line but it was
like this
so I thought he lost his place because I
couldn't hear him right he says I know I
set the line I'm waiting on you I'm like
oh
the whole night okay
we're on The Graham Norton Show and I
have some friends
oh no quick I'll be back
there is no bathroom
now and what does he do I'm old not
obsolete
[Applause]
I'll be back this is really embarrassing
to do in front of a whole room full of
Brits here but I'll try it anyways so
it's like
it's like honestly I like I saw this guy
[Applause]
Michael cheat on me when he was in a
beef heart and I was like because he was
telling me he's like you know you know I
miss you or whatever and I'm not
miss me what am I your mother
[Applause]
before before you did an incredible
Chewbacca but I'm told you also do a Jar
Jar Binks
[Music]
[Applause]
oh no that's a big sea monster
I think everyone does an impression of
Christopher Walken because he's just
he's such an easy kind you know I feel
like what this show needs
is more cowbell
depends on what
you'd like me to say
basically there's no
punctuation
anything that comes out of my mouth
I like that
you do impressions as well Bradley don't
you sometimes if you want me to talk I
just whatever comes into my head I'll
say I don't know when or what it's going
to be
[Applause]
yeah
Christopher Walker
so it's on Family Guy Family Guy if I go
the characters you do you do Peter uh
Brian Stewie Quagmire and then a
smattering of others needed and are they
all based on people are you just they're
they come from various places Peter I
knew a thousand Peter Griffins growing
up in in New England guys who would not
think before they spoke like every no
shelf editing mechanism
it's coming out here with no Gateway and
um and when you're doing because you
know those characters are in scenes
together yeah do you do one line after
the other or do you all do old one and
then go back and do the other one when I
do a table read yeah I have to jump back
and forth so it's like hey what's going
on hello fat man all right Stewie how
are you
of course
it's good right that is good
I was just telling a story about
midnight in Paris the Woody Allen film I
was in and how I never read the whole
script and I and I thought it was set in
the 20s and um I turned up and I bombed
his own Wilson who didn't look like he
was in the 20s at all
and uh and I said to him I said so wait
hang on who are you playing because I'm
playing F Scott Fitzgerald and I know
Corey stalls playing Ernest Hemingway
and we're all playing figures of history
and he went oh no no no no no no I'm
from now I go back
there's a time machine
it's kind of cool and it's kind of Woody
and you just kind of it's kind of
Awesome
there was a director of Joel Schumacher
who's very funny man very tall very sort
of eccentric and he would direct with a
speaker and a with a microphone and a
speaker usually directors will come up
and say hey he'll be like okay and you'd
hear this you know giant booming voice
and I'm
bolted into this suit I can't move and
he would literally go and he would
direct you like as if you would have
some emotional scene he would go okay
people all right uh George your your
parents or dad you have nothing to live
for
I'm Batman
[Applause]
tonight
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
what the cool
I feel like like dance monkey but like I
just got a big stick do this
well you're an Irishman you think these
people accept you as one of their own
but they did they didn't accept you at
all
um yeah so Brian we'd like some Cool
Whip
why are you saying it like that what do
I say I'm saying Cool Whip
what's up
okay
[Applause]
I'll do one do one line of Tom what line
should I do I don't know I don't know I
feel the need the Need for Speed
that's good
you're good at it
[Applause]
I used to be able to do Sean Connery oh
yeah you could in fact sometimes I I
would call up my agent and say uh hello
this is Sean Connery
to Adela matto please and I'd
immediately get through
I'm only kidding this Liam
yeah
you do Donald Duck yeah do you do it
okay now it's your turn oh
that's about the dragon is back he is
aggressive finish business I
as as a voice but there isn't I mean
obviously it's put through treatments
and things but actually yes it sounds
very like
what you did oh God do you want me to do
that as well you can
um
oh my God
it's your heart beating
faster
wow that's on the wrong side for my mom
that's Clint Eastwood described it says
you hit a few marks you say a few lines
what's the problem
very good
[Applause]
so when you're in a Clint Eastwood movie
you don't even know the camera's rolling
and you just hear over your shoulder
all right go ahead
[Laughter]
him
you know
you do what you sometimes are doing some
pretty hot stuff and you just keep doing
it until you hear him say
and that's and then you move on and
you're on to the next setup it's
intimidating as hell please record your
audio so you press zero
read that and then you press
zero is that one right
I start yeah I don't know who you are I
don't have any money
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh that's so good
but when I do have
on a very specific set of skills
skills that make me a nightmare
for somebody like you
I think I'm about my daughter go now I
will find you
and I will kill you
do a British accent don't you
I've been working on it
okay
but my friends and colleagues don't
think it's very good
keep yourself short it was very good at
the beginning
Anne Hathaway Mistress of the accent yes
can you do Cockney go on and give it a
go babe
all right love you want me to give it a
go
we were talking with uh Antonio and
Salma about you know their difficulties
with English when they got to America
sure but in this tour this is good
um you do a kind of Master Class in
accents well I was trying to get better
I've been doing like I've been a
stand-up comedian for like 10 years and
I was trying to get better at it I
thought what can I get better at and
it's accents so I've gone away
discovered the secret of doing like good
Regional accents is you need a key
phrase to get you started if you're
doing the accent once you get that key
phrase in your head then you get started
I could teach you like smacks I can't do
yours I could do ones from around
Britain I could do to be useful you see
because then you could start playing
British people and you know sure Meryl
Streep gets them all now and you know
you could be in Desperate scouse wives
so like the Scout sacks and so if you
want to talk like someone from Liverpool
you say this this phrase you say foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
because then once you say it then you
can say something properly authentically
Scouts like you said I want some chicken
I'm going on the Rob I've got to get a
Prezi it's me Gran's birthday she's 30.
story and I think it's a cockney accent
I'm not sure when we were filming Batman
there's this one day we were filming in
central London and Christian was walking
to set and there are these two boys and
they're sitting there and they're
staring at him and one of them goes oi
you Batman
and the other one goes no he's not
Batman look at his teeth
whatever that means
Believers Believers we have a message
from your leader
[Applause]
hey what about hey wait wait hello how
are you you like my English accent
it's very nice very well thank you
Cheerio
so I like I like British accents because
they're so sexy
[Applause]
how much is it it's about champ and 50.
that's the same thing we say in Long
Beach how much is it
one last one for Usher what have you got
for us
oh this
um
[Applause]
you have to mention uh Braveheart one of
everybody's for everybody's favorite
what's up
the Scottish action in that how hard was
that for you it was difficult but I was
up there and immersed among people who
all needed subtitles
what did you saying they'd have to
repeat it So eventually it kind of
worked its way into my lexicon and is it
true that Sean Connery helped you
at dinner one night he did and he used
we were having we were at Andy vanya's
place and he's Hungarian and he made
goulash now imagine Sean Connery saying
that word
he said I always have rules with my
goulash
unrelated words but if you want to do
the Geordie accent
how people talk from Newcastle those
words
roller coaster
that's right okay
okay
roller coaster roller coaster
[Music]
[Applause]
the way I even met and I did I blew it I
didn't blow it but it worked out
it's not making sense because I haven't
told you the story yet but what happened
was that I'm throwing a party for I
thought all these parties in my crib so
I'm throwing a party for puff and
Jay-Z's there and Pharrell's a big party
and this kid walks in with his with a
backpack on and his Jaws busted and I
said who's that and they said that's
Kanye West I said what do you do he said
he raps and you know he he produces for
Jay-Z I said well everybody comes to my
house got to perform I gotta I gotta I
gotta see what this dude had so I walked
into him and I said yo man they say you
do your thing you know you're right and
he killed with this freestyle was
amazing I said wow but you're gonna be
famous right and then he said to me said
he said uh uh I have a a song that that
I think that you would be great on uh if
we could go uh to the studio and do uh
that song I said man what I'm trying to
get in the music business let's go
because I wasn't in the music business
and it happened to have a studio in my
crib so we go in the back
we heard that yeah
but the reason I did that because I
would throw parties was for musical
people so I could try to get on the
record so
and he says the song uh goes uh she says
she wants a Marvin Gaye some Luther
Vandross I say I got I got I gotta she
said she who wants some more I've been
good yeah he said yo what are you doing
I said well I you know you don't know
you don't know r b see I'm R B singers I
got to put the r b thing on it see I got
to do that he said uh don't do that
I said just seeing it simple because
it's you know it's hip-hop and I was
like all right so I sung it begrudgingly
thinking this song is whack he's not
gonna make it it's not gonna work right
so I left and I went and did a bad movie
and I came back
a jacket
[Music]
I went to a bad movie and I can't really
did it though
it really took a chance
I do this bad movie I come back and I'm
in Miami and my boy was like yo remember
that song you said was whack is number
one in the country wow and so that's how
uh that's how you get it wrong but right
sometimes yeah that's him both of you
Michael Jackson was a real hero of yours
um and yeah so now you you did you miss
him or you didn't meet him there was a
no no I never I never no I talked to him
on the phone yes how did that happen uh
I would how did it happen I was I was in
Paris and I was with uh Kenny Ortega we
were promoting High School Musical three
I want to say it was it was probably 20
maybe 20 21 at the time and we were at
dinner and um somehow I got that was at
the head of the table and Kenny was on
the other side of the table our director
Kenny Ortega and um his phone rang and I
remember I got this look like
you want this film I was like okay so I
came over and I was like what's what's
going on he goes it's Michael Jack I'm
like what okay answer the phone and I
was like uh hello and I heard
um hi who's this
I was like
um this is Zac Efron and I'm a massive
fan and I'm an actor and and you're like
my hero and I didn't know what to say I
was like kind of I was just at a loss
for words and uh rambling on and then he
said that's really nice can you hand the
phone back to Kenny
and I I was freaking out like I just
talked to Michael Jackson he's my hero I
was tripping
um and I sat back down just a little
dizzy and then all of a sudden the phone
rang again and um Kenny answered and I
saw him kind of confused across the
table and and uh
he like looked at me again he's like
you want to skip it I was like okay and
he hands in front of me he goes it's
it's Michael Jackson again yeah I was
like
I was like what okay and I picked up the
phone I was like hello and he goes oh
this is Zach from High School Musical
and I was like uh yeah and he was like
oh I'm I love what you do I'm a huge fan
and I lost it
I lost my balance I think I fell over
into the wall I started I was like you
know who I am and I just started crying
I was I was a mess like literally I was
just making a fool out of myself I like
slid down to the floor pathetically and
professed how much I loved him said look
you're my hero you're the reason I do
what I do like thank you so much Michael
for everything and uh thanks for showing
me how to dance how to be you know how
to how to believe in myself how to how
to I don't know how to shine you know
and um
that made him cry
both crying to each other on the phone
and he ended the whole phone call
conversation with um something along the
lines of hey Zach and I like stopped
crying for a second he's like isn't it
isn't it awesome and I was like what and
he goes dreams really do come true don't
they when I was like oh
[Applause]
because I went to see Michael in concert
the other day yeah I did it was so good
I saw your films as well it was very
good
it was nice too because I could see you
there was a point where I was singing
and I looked back and all I saw you you
had I think a glass of wine of course I
did yeah
I saw it very clearly and the other
you're doing this
Jennifer haven't you yes I was on her
special yeah and we've we've met up at
different functions and things yeah yeah
and have you met Damon Judy James before
no we have now hi yes it's nice to meet
you
and now I don't know does Matthew know
that he plays a special part in your
life
uh no probably not please I play a
special part in your life yeah can't
wait to hear this well I mean I my wife
and I sleep with you almost every night
yes yes
and every night there's an app called
com
and I have insomnia and he has the most
beautiful voice and I turn it on and I
just hear where hello everybody
it's me Matthew McConaughey I'm gonna
tell you a bedtime story and I just do
this oh
that's my wife who's from Argentina she
always goes like you have the man
talking again
well it was well worth it no no we've
got a little gift because I just thought
it was you reading stories but you are
actually putting people to bed this is
this is Matthew McConaughey on the app
tonight
I hope to send you off to Peaceful
dreams with that very thing in mind
let your eyes close and your breath
Falls soft and slow
as we begin our story
which just might rekindle
that sense of wonder
oh yeah
Kendrick you've noticed something about
British people and the way they speak
that we do a funny thing well
we think it's well and I mean I love all
the
into that scone mess
um uh but I I like that because there's
so many accents to such a small country
everybody sort of puts on different
voices when they're doing little bits
and stuff but I had a thing where uh I
was checking into a hotel
and somebody came out and said oh do you
need help with your bags and I thought
they were doing a bit
um I went oh I've been traveling all day
you have no idea
um kept talking like that so I had to
like slowly transition out of it and I
know that that sounds like an
exaggeration of their voice but then I
was back in the country several years
later and they were on TV on gogglebox
because it was Steph and Dom from Gotham
so they actually talk like that that is
I never knew that that was a real hotel
yeah yeah you stayed there yeah and
accidentally made fun of them to their
face
I guess Alan what's that story you have
about the your is it yeah a very good
friend of mine she was going for a
really stressful time and a lovely aunt
said listen I'm going to get you a head
massage so she went to this Clinic had a
head massage she was in the room and the
woman said uh can you take your knickers
off
a bit weird for a head massage okay okay
yes so she took her knickers off and
she's like that
and then the woman came back in she was
South African she went no Nicholas
Nicholas
oh
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yeah we call it a necklace
[Applause]
off I get it you mentioned Bolton in
your school yes this is so sweet I
didn't I haven't seen this picture
before this is uh you in school and
you've sort of changed a lot and not
changed at all this is you just in there
and
what were you what were you giving well
that was a play called fry bacon and
fried bunghes Elizabethan played written
about Shakespeare's time and I was
playing the young heroine but there were
girls in school
you can't quite see the boy in the sixth
form who I was madly in love with do you
want to try and find him uh Brian is
quite handsome that one no never mind
I don't know him
[Laughter]
I mean it's a good game but uh I'm not
sure I'm not sure I'll get it yeah
he might be just out of shot I think yes
oh dear and people obviously get very
excited when you go on tour and places
rather so you've got a blue plaque
haven't you most people have to die to
get a blue
package oh have you I've got one on the
house where I was born in Burnley but I
I did go and visit it on my second only
visit to Burnley because we left when I
was two months old and I think they put
it on the wrong house
no this other one is in Liverpool I
think or Leeds I think it's live we
thought it was leads but I think we
think it's Liverpool yes yes well what
was I doing there I think I can tell you
what you were doing there I can tell you
what you're doing there
see you Miguel and sat here on table
five and enjoyed a jacket potato
hahaha
I don't precisely what you were doing
there yeah
where do you know where that is it's
it's on the University campus oh okay
yes was it a nice potato
Liverpool's looking gorgeous these days
since they've done it up oh
go to Liverpool when I was a kid and it
was a dangerous and dirty and dank Place
pre-beatles everything but now of course
it's it's spanking it's terrific oh it's
beautiful now yes and in the show
obviously you'll be you know as you said
you'll be talking about Shakespeare and
doing scenes yes but you'll be uh also
telling stories about your your life and
why not people you've worked with
there's a story actually dangerous try
don't ask me just tell another Maggie
Smith story no
every time I see her she said you've not
been doing me again
now you've done her again
[Laughter]
it is traditional at this point in the
show when John Bishop is on the couch to
turn to the Americans to say
understanding anything
no no I'm getting it on everything oh
yeah yeah good good he said he was in
The Fellowship of the Ring
because talking talking of accents this
is a weird thing so Chris Pratt is this
this seems so unlikely that you have now
learned how to do the voices from towie
yeah sort of yeah
we love that garbage TV back in
that's crazy about it and when I was
here filming Guardians we shot Guardians
the Galaxy here in in London and and my
wife Anna came out to visit
and she fell in love with this show
towie The Only Way is Essex it's this
show that's like basically their Jersey
shores the Jersey Shore from right from
here it's like this uh town somewhere
Essex I guess and
these folks are just like the worst and
it was like I'm a parrot a little bit
and so when I hear when I hear it all
the time I just started picking it up
and started like I could pick up their
accent and do their accent a little bit
yeah I'm okay this is gonna sound right
it's really embarrassing to do in front
of a whole room full of Brits here but
I'll try it anyways so it's like
so I honestly like I saw this guy
you're like Michael cheated on me when
he was in a beef heart and I was like
because he was telling me he's like you
know and I I miss you or whatever
miss me what am I your mother
[Applause]
that will never be useful that would be
useful but that's very good now I want
to watch the show
I love the fact that you spent months in
Italy and that's what you can talk about
I've read will that you have uh this
amazing amount of music that you haven't
released but tracks with extraordinary
artists like Michael Jackson and Prince
and people like that will you ever
release those tracks uh no because you
know especially artists like Michael
Jackson were working with Michael
Jackson is his critique and his two
cents so you know without him guiding on
completing it it's not my right to to do
that he was a friend so I wouldn't I
wouldn't do that and what was the story
that you brought Michael Jackson and
Princess yes
you you brought Michael Jackson and
Prince together yeah so one time we had
a show in um in Vegas and Michael
Jackson called
hey what's Michael
yeah so I heard you guys are doing a
show tonight yeah we're going at nine
o'clock all right so I gotta put the
kids to sleep
so I was like well I'm performing with
Prince later on at 12. so anyways
Michael came to see me rock with Prince
and it was a it was a magnificent night
to see it was me Chris Tucker and then
Watching Me Chris Tucker Michael Jackson
watching Prince rock on stage so to make
a long story short Prince steps off the
stage and plays the bass in Michael
Jackson's face rips the freaking face in
10 different pieces like a longer story
shorter Michael Jackson leaves and goes
home and says leave me in the house for
breakfast so I go to his house for
breakfast knock on the door first words
he says where was Prince playing the
bass in my face
[Laughter]
no no Prince he's just being nice you
know no Prince he's always been a meanie
thank you
stay there I'm enjoying this introduce
buddy Tyler right it's time for music
very good
and yeah don't we I mean it's either
music or it's or it's it's voices or
tons of voices I mean you know I used to
muck around addictive phones at school
for ages and just you know do
interpretations on impersonations of
people and create characters and it's
just sort of having an ear it's part of
what we do I guess I mean even if it's
not a real person just to imitate or
have empathy with a state or a human
being of any general you were doing
Chewbacca during the clip was I in time
with the Chewbacca thing just a natural
ninja that's one of my favorite
Chewbacca moments is just that
[Applause]
but Benedict is pretty good at acting
the uh the screening I know
philosophy who you did me and you were
very good you did my laugh very well
yeah
that's it last time as you said you were
here with Harrison Ford before you did
an incredible Chewbacca but I'm told you
also do a Jar Jar Binks
[Applause]
oh no it's a big sea monster
you don't make much money out of doing a
good charger let me tell you that yeah
rightfully so in my opinion and uh as
found the dragon is back he is yeah uh
aggressive Finnish business
that as as a voice but there isn't I
mean obviously it's put through
treatments and things but actually yes
it sounds very like
what you did oh God do you want me to do
that as well you can
um
[Applause]
beating
faster
wow I was on the wrong side to my mind
[Applause]
I'm
very confused right now
[Applause]
what have you been doing
um well you know just celebrating oh
wait a minute oh I've got something for
you really Michael yeah
don't let this out it's your birthday on
Tuesday but you shouldn't have you saw
my embarrassment
it's a beautiful president thank you so
much oh it's a lovely card with a
picture of Michael on the front now is
this one this is one of the talking
cards yeah yeah okay let's have a listen
let's listen
remember
[Applause]
is that a good one oh yeah yeah it's a
good impressive yeah but the best
impression of my voice I've heard is Tom
Hanks
really he did it on the on The Late Show
in in New York yeah as I saw him I was
surprised
Tom Hanks and he never done it for me
and do you know this there's this
shortcut to say your name as the way it
Impressions people say you say my
cocaine yeah like the drug but loud yeah
but I'll tell you a story about that oh
yes I was making a picture I was making
a picture in the Philippines and I'm in
Manila and we were invited to this very
very Posh expensive house to a party and
I'm being introduced to people and
understanding getting a drink and all
that and the hostess is standing over
there
and she's looking at me rather nicely
considering I'm a guest you know like
and I there was a moment when I was a
bit free and she went
so I went over her and she said
are you a drug dealer
I said no why do you ask she said why is
everybody calling you my cocaine
you know that story is true because you
couldn't make it up
a lot of people at the party going
where's my cocaine
not you
[Music]